it's Halloween the media say better
watch out
Halloween is the deadliest holiday
within minutes this little pirate
costume disintegrated people are
injecting gummies just like this these
days with drugs really that's what we
should worry about no that's absurd
those stories have been around for
decades they're not true though adults
find plenty of other things to worry
about what do you fear in Hollywood I'm
scared of bats
yes do you really think they might
really hurt you I think so because their
wings are flapping and they're really
long jerks I hate rats men I guess like
creepy old people uh-oh does that
include me I am terrified of spiders
she believes many Americans are killed
by spiders I'm gonna go with at least a
thousand actually free this is the
National Safety Council balloons horses
and you think you're more likely to be
killed by a horse than other risks
probably not but it's our fears are
often not very logical exactly people
fear anything that's creepy and an
unknown right I'm super afraid of like
clowns clowns what clothes and they're
just a little freaky I'm scared they're
gonna chase after me I just saw it so I
think I'm in that kind of clown yeah I
think that's what I'm scared of right
now Americans worry about so much what
might actually physically harm you gosh
what couldn't kill you over nowadays
like murder maybe everybody's crazy
these days mean people Trump what scares
you
Heights white height because I can't
control it
aha there's an insight losing control
adds to our feeders in cars we feel in
control
but flying scares many people I got on a
plane today and I was freaking out hold
on
there are more than 90 deaths a day from
car crash but no one's died for years
and a commercial American plane I'm
scared of getting hit by the subway
there's a lot of things that scare me
today there's a lot of things going on
in our world that is scary no wait
despite all the media hype about a
thousand risks life the day is safer
than ever before it's not good to fear
so much because fear is a friend of big
government whenever there's an accident
the media push politicians to say there
ought to be a law ban all consumer
fireworks and worried people agree no I
don't think they should be allowed
unless they're done by professionals
vicious dogs need to be regulated now
and grab you and kill you we are in
grave danger frankly in this country
because of terrorism terrorism is the
big scare now but even including a 911
death from terrorism is rare the
National Safety Council says more people
die crossing the street in bathtubs or
tripping over furniture here in Times
Square the risk of terrorism is probably
higher but this man understands it's
still a small risk because if you look
at the odds you've look at the numbers
it's it's very small the big risks in
America today are eating too much
drinking too much smoking and driving
recklessly what do you worry about bad
drivers you know that's the most
sensible answer I've gotten here all day
happy Halloween enjoy the moment life in
America is safer than ever before
you
you